so Sifu and Ninja have had a
long-standing beef and you know Ninja
has said openly little bit I don't I
don't want to fight you man I don't I
don't care like that so what's the beef
just with fortnight's stuff no no yeah
so anyway the beef here is that for the
mr. beast event no I mean like what's
that what's where does it stem from that
I don't know okay I think T food just
he's just kind of a he's kind of a just
a a bro he's in flow vote ninja dude I
still [ __ ] like I don't like it's
[ __ ] here yeah I think it's probably
something that stems from fortnight
someone probably said something about
another player and or ninja probably I
would imagine went on one of his rants
and then T foo said oh that's [ __ ]
dumb and then maybe yeah
ninja personally goes shut up dude it's
not just a game it's real anyway yeah so
from the mr. beast event T foo was part
of it and they were all instructed don't
stream it but T food did and he wild
live he's tabbing around and he opens up
his Twitter dams in front of I don't
know how many people are watching a
stream and he leaks the zoom code to the
event so the the conference gets rated
which is you know that's solvable but
then he leaks it's through peace phone
number which is just oh and the people
were so shitty in the replies to T Fuu
saying ah man I [ __ ] up people were
just posting screenshots and other
people are saying dude why are you
posting it it's [ __ ] up and someone
says I mean it's already out there dude
might as well show it no just do your
part mitigate the damage be a friend
that's that [ __ ] by the way this all
happened within the first like five
minutes of the of the thing going live
so it was Tana and David was the first
round and they were playing and this is
and then often that's [ __ ] got rated so
it's not like mr. B's could get a new
emergency phone number in order to
contact all these people and be like hey
we're working on fixing this yeah like
that I've been like the most stressful
situation for him yeah and he is not a
dude that strikes me as someone who gets
stressed out yeah you know he seems
pretty level-headed so I would imagine
that tested the [ __ ] out of him but also
I wonder how quick his phone just
started getting lit up with [ __ ]
yeah anyway so ninja says something
about to I don't know what prompted this
but T foo goes off on ninja on his
stream right here ninjas shouldn't be
talking [ __ ] cuz he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] he
needs to keep keep his goddamn mouth
shut
alright I'm sorry dude that is the most
non-threatening keep his mouth shut
I've ever heard ninja is a [ __ ] and he
needs to keep his mouth shut
it's just very matter-of-fact which
maybe makes it scarier I don't know
needs to keep his mouth shut
yeah hey ninja you beep I'm gonna say it
you need to keep your mouth shut
he's more [ __ ] offended than [ __ ]
Beast Prabhas ninjas in the chat
spamming my name over and over and
tweeting about me like tell him that
he's a frail ass [ __ ] ass cotton candy
had asked [ __ ] all right and he's lucky
this is rock-paper-scissors because if
this was a [ __ ] fight you're
something bro hmm this was a real
fighter song bro could you imagine mr.
beast I'm holding the ultimate youtuber
boxing tournament for a zillion dollars
I thought it was funny too I thought it
was funny to like threaten someone to a
fight right now especially yeah yeah but
he didn't even threaten him he's just
like if if this was who's dreaming a
fight and I was in it hopefully I'd be
against ninja yeah and yeah I would
definitely regret what he said
especially during his quarantine is like
that's so far from ever happening kind
of a funny way to threaten someone but I
mean if ninja was in the chat spamming
his name that's a little bit childish
yeah I wonder I wonder yeah maybe he was
but anyways isn't the whole controversy
is because they were told not to stream
it because it was for charity so the
more people on the main stream right the
more likely they are to donate which
totally is valid criticism yeah 100% I
think that was that was a bit as a
bonehead move
you